ça fait quelques jours que je teste le
one + 6 t il vient d'être annoncé est
directement par mois de plus et j'ai eu
la chance de la voir en avant première
depuis quelques bonnes journées donc de
bien tester voir vraiment comment il est
et ce qui permettait de faire s'il était
bien oui non tous havre a beaucoup
aujourd'hui on profite d'un test
vraiment en avant première pour parler
du wan +67 vraiment vous donner tout mon
retour mon expérience vous dire si je le
trouve bien quelles sont vraiment les
les nouveautés par rapport au mois de
plus si ce qui est sorti il ya quelques
mois et au final est-ce qu'il faut
l'acheter ou oui quoi non comment on est
là
[Musique]
j'avais déjà trouvé une piste vraiment
excellents mais inclure une puce system
en plus va beaucoup plus loin je vous
montre il ya vraiment quelques gros gros
gros points d'amélioration à commencer
par l'encoche mais le truc moi qui me en
tout cas le plus tripes et c'est le
capteur pour déverrouiller c'est à dire
que vous avez soins du faisceau noc qui
marche extrêmement bien
tout de suite il reconnaît mon visage
c'est d'une rapidité incroyable appel
j'appuie me reconnais je me planque un
peu derrière la caméra il voit pas fabre
médicale
il me reconnaît et deaveiro tout de
suite c'est vraiment hyper hyper
appréciable mais ce que j'adore là
dessus moi c'est le capteur d'empreintes
digitales directement intégrée elle
qu'on leur démontre avec les mauvaises
lois
bush une espèce énorme lumière autour
tout ça vraiment magnifique et
maintenant je pose le bon doit pas fait
ça déverrouille directement ça
fonctionne extrêmement bien c'est
vraiment génial et autres points
vraiment qui est tout nouveau ce que
j'adore aussi ses petites encoches tout
minuscule tout petit il ya ceux qui
n'aiment pas les en cause ma qui
continueront à pas les aimer mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya un vrai effort qui est
arrivé à roanne plus une encoche qui est
beaucoup plus petit et surtout qu'on
peut complètement désactivé
ça c'est aussi pratique il vous suffit
d'aller dans vos paramètres vous allez
dans affichage affichage de l'encoche et
claque vous cliquez là votre encoches a
disparu vous n'avez plus d'encoches vous
retrouvez avec une grande bordure sur le
haut bon je trouve ça un peu moins sympa
qu'à voir cette toute petite encoche
donc du coup ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
va à la réactiver pense qu'en termes de
design trouve que vous non plus a
vraiment fait un excellent boulot avec
soan pucistes et qui reste dans la
continuité de ce qu'on avait quelques
mois auparavant
le smartphone est pas énorme il va
mesurer 157,5 par 74,8 effet 8,2 mm
d'épaisseur le pot est pas énorme il
fait 185 g
donc ça va très bien ici un très très
bien dans la main et tout de suite très
facile à déverrouiller ça c'est un vrai
plaisir
les couleurs restent inchangés vous avez
soit le miroir black swan midnight black
produit très sympa maintenant on va
regarder du côté de l'écran de la face
avant vous avez un écran qui est plus
grand sur le point de plus si vous avez
un écran de 6,28 pouces là vous avez un
écran de 6,41 pouces c'est toujours de
l'amoled et la définition est un peu
plus élevé
2340 par 1080 alors qu'avant vous aviez
dû 2280 par 1080
bon ça c'est aussi appréciable un écran
qui occuperait 86% de la face avant
quand je me regarde comme ça j'ai
l'impression qu'il occupe beaucoup plus
86% la face avant les bons c'est ce que
dit one plus à noter vous avez ratio de
19 points 5/9 vraiment énorme toujours
plus énormes on finit par se demander ce
n'arrivera pas bientôt avec des ratios
de vingt neuvième passé c'est vraiment
énorme
en été vous avez aussi un verre corning
gorilla glass 6 à l'avant donc très
résistant robuste un grand écran que je
trouve vraiment très très lumineuse là
c'est pas du tout pousser la luminosité
à fond et vous allez voir lorsque je la
pousse à fond ça claque vraiment alors
attention ne pas vous abîmer les yeux
parce que c'est toujours un petit peu le
les risques qu'on a là dessus ce qui
était vraiment bien pensé aussi là
dessus si vous voulez vraiment vous
protéger les yeux vous avez dans vos
paramètres paramètres toujours
d'affichage au niveau du calibrage de
l'écran déjà il faut choisir du srg bdc
ip3 mon adaptatif vous pouvez
personnaliser à quelque chose d'un peu
plus chaud ou d'un peu plus froid en
fonction des besoins alors attention en
lumière bleue toujours moi je les
laissais par défaut elle un peu plus de
couleur bleue à l'intérieur ça
fonctionne pas mal justement pour lutter
contre la couleur bleue vous avez une
mode nocturne qui a vraiment venir vous
protéger un pelage active l'âge les
paramétrer automatiquement pour qu'ils
se mettent du coucher au lever du soleil
mais vous pouvez l'activer il advenir un
petit peu plus jeune vous aurez moins de
lumière bleue bon pas mal de paramètres
à se réfugia c'est plutôt cool et vous
avez aussi un mode lecture vous pouvez
venir bloquer des notifications par
exemple si vous voulez pas être embêté
si vous voulez lire tranquillement il ya
pas mal de petites choses de ce point de
vue là je trouve que ça c'est vraiment
intéressant aussi maintenant l'écran est
vraiment bien et lorsque vous la
regardez des vidéos vous en profiter
vraiment c'est plutôt sympa mais vous
pouvez venir paf vous avons dit c'est
l'encoche est tout petit ça dérange pas
énormément et c'est vraiment hyper
agréable alors après on peut regretter
c'est servir un petit peu kron p en
fonction des vidéos vous allez regarder
vous manque un petit peu la formation en
haut et en bas
sa saga du ratio 19 points 5/9 mais dans
l'absolu c'est quand même plutôt pas mal
en termes de puissance c'est pas mal les
faucons pauvreté
c'est que vous n'avez qu'un haut parleur
mono ici voilà ça c'est un peu plus qu'à
fermer pas fondées sur un smartphone
premium sera trouvé ça vraiment bien que
le petit haut parleur vous avez l'aï
juste caché là qui vous sert à passer
beaucoup de fils puisse venir en renfort
alors d'un côté il est tout petit
vraiment tout discret juste là on n'a
peut-être pas suffisamment de puissance
quand tu comme on est vraiment temps de
la miniaturisation avec une toute petite
encoche ici si on veut vraiment un haut
parleur qui est vraiment très léger très
caché et qui vraiment ça t'es qu'un
complètement design on n'a peut-être pas
assez de puissance pour un mois voir du
haut parleurs stéréo
lorsqu on va regarder des vidéos du coup
vous avez juste à vous parleur mono là
c'est peut-être un point de regret sur
ce smartphone que je trouve malgré tout
vraiment bien alors la puissance elle
est vraiment cool ici lorsque vous le
mettez je me sens pas du tout les et la
qualité et bien franchement ça envoie du
bois ça fonctionne ça vous aura
peut-être pas échappé moi je suis un
assez grand fan des prises jack qui
reste sur les smartphones et aujourd'hui
disparaissent de plus en plus là dessus
vous avez absolument aucune prise jack
donc si vous voulez écouter au casque
vous pouvez soit acheter des petits
écouteurs one plus qu'ils sont vraiment
bien et qui sont complètement en usb
type c dont vous venez poser vos
écouteurs à l'intérieur et franchement
la qualité est super bien tienne
extrêmement bien dans vos oreilles
la limite ça vous coûte même un peu
l'extérieur tous que ça fonctionne super
bien
j'enlève abscons pour parler c'est hyper
dur il ya beaucoup de sons et il ya
vraiment des basques est une qualité qui
est assez incroyable
les médiums sont dont les élus aussi
franchement je dois reconnaître que ces
petits écouteurs de votre plus
fonctionne extrêmement bien
c'est un vrai plaisir par contre si je
vais utiliser mon vieux casque avec ma
prise jack
je peux toujours le faire parce que loin
de plus garde dans ses boîtes pas
l'adaptateur usb type c'est vers port
jack donc ça ça fonctionne maintenant ce
que j'aime moins c'est que ça pendu un
peu de tous les côtés ça c'est aussi un
peu le point de regret mais bon on peut
pas tout avoir là dessus à côté de ça ça
fonctionne
il ya du son règne approcher la qualité
est là dont bon on va passer très très
rapidement sur la partie photo vidéo je
vous ferai une vidéo complètement dédié
pour en parler parce que pas mal de
choses à dire dessus on va quand même
faire un point ce côté un peu technique
vous avez à l'arrière un double module
photo ça vous le voyez je peux pas vous
le cacher une caméra principale de 16
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f
1.7 donc
et lumineuse taille de pixel de 1.2
micromètres donc c'est pareil pour la
faible luminosité ça va être vraiment
bien
tous sont tous des capteurs soleil à
l'avant comme à l'arrière si vous avez
une deuxième caméra 20 mégapixels
ouverture également de f1 points 7 donc
plus infâmes de luminosité c'est
vraiment bien vous postulez en 4k
jusqu'à 60 images par seconde
vous avez une stabilisation optique
enfin un truc qui est vraiment top il ya
l'avant dans cette petite partie de ces
petites encoches vous avez aussi une
caméra sony de 16 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de f 2.0 moins lumineuses et
vous pouvez filmer jusqu'en 1080p à 30
images par seconde que vous avez du hdr
vous avez de la photo de nuit vous
pouvez faire du slow motion en 1080p à
240 images par seconde ou alors en 720p
à 480 images par seconde mais tout ça on
va le détail ici quelques jours donc je
vous invite à vous abonner
on reste connectés et on verra ça tous
ensemble et maintenant les performances
parce que moins de puces a fait un
excellent travail au niveau des
performances alors en termes de fiche
technique on reste sans la même chose
qu'on avait avec le one + 6 slovène
pucistes est une évolution du web + 6
néanmoins une vraie optimisation ça
fonctionne très très bien ça va vite
très vite extrêmement vite je vous
montre ça c'est vraiment bluffant
il ya un truc qui est juste extrêmement
bien la rapidité c'est le déverrouillage
mains de trois objets apparaissent à
déverrouille tout de suite c'est
vraiment très très très rapide faut dire
que vous avez la puissance là dedans
vous avez un stade ragots 845 côté j'ai
pu c'est une adreno 630 vous avez deux
versions soit 6 giga de ram soit 8 gigas
de ram
ça c'est la version 8 gigas de ram vous
avez ensuite en stockage soit 128 go de
stockage soit 256 go de stockage
je vous ai fait un petit benchmark sur
en tout où vous allez voir le truc
complètement hallucinant on un score de
297 1317 je ne sais pas si ça vous parle
celui qui a le plus gros score tout de
suite c'est le rock funk le rock phone
hop il a le score de 299 1706 est
derrière vous avez le me black shark qui
a été pendant très longtemps premier qui
a aussi eu 8 gigas de ram 128 gia de
stockage et qui est à 290 1602 autant
vous dire qu'avec un score de 297 1317
on est franchement au dessus alors bon
là j'ai la version les giga de ram avec
une version 6 giga de ram on sera en
deçà néanmoins ces vraies fusées une
vraie bête de compet c'est hallucinant
dans classements en tout ou le one piece
est sorti à quelques mois
gadrat de 256 go de stockage avaient un
score de 289 1424 donc là le score est
encore au dessus sur booster pour voir
qu'on a les mêmes spec à savoir à son
dragon 845 8 gigas de ram
ça prouve bien qu'une vraie optimisation
logiciel là dessus et c'est vraiment
hallucinant
en plus vous avez un truc qui est super
sympa qui s'appelle le mode jeu alors ça
y est vous détaille dans quelques
instants contre on parle un peu de la
partie logicielle on a une vraie
optimisation optimisation des
performances pour cpu pour gpu optimisés
pour la mémoire et là on peut choisir on
peut répondre aux appels via les
haut-parleurs si l'on veut pendant le
jeu maintien on va se mettre répondre
aux appels tiers on peut aussi bloquer
l'affichage des notifications on peut
vraiment aller loin là dessus avec ce
mode jeu mêlant va se faire une petite
partie de pib en termes d'expérience de
jeu c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
fluide
je trouve que p&g fonctionne extrêmement
bien la thuringe et regarde pas ce cas
des mecs qui veut le but un peu de tous
les côtés on va vraiment toute la
puissance de ce one + 6 t directement
sur pib j'ai ça fonctionne extrêmement
bien
c'est hyper fluide y est absolument pas
de zone de latence qui rien ne retient
pas ça lag absolument pas c'est vraiment
très rapide c'est vraiment hyper
appréciable parce que ça va tout de
suite extrêmement vite et pour des
parties gaming sur un pib j'ai ça
fonctionne vraiment bien c'est hyper
appréciable et on a beaucoup de
puissance beaucoup de performances d'art
ya donc au terre plein de jeunes ya pas
que pib j'ai tous les jeux qui seront un
peu gourmands vont extrêmement bien
tourné là dessus et ça c'est vraiment
génial
parlons maintenant autonomie il ya une
batterie à l'intérieur qui est un peu
plus grosse que celle du one + 6 sur
votre fussistes vous avez une batterie
de 3300 milliards erreur là vous avez
deux batteries de 3700 milliards eur
mais qui est complètement optimisé d'un
point de vue logiciel
d'un point de vue performances au niveau
du stade rigole 845 le fait d'avoir de
la ram derrière forcément ça va aider la
machine
le ce la preuve regardez beaucoup plus
durer une journée me franchement vous
les faites si vous n'êtes pas bourrin
faisait pas tout le temps dessus vous
aurez absolument aucun problème
les choix 82% batterie me marre qu'il me
reste plus de deux jours alors
effectivement ça va dépendre de votre
utilisation sous dit un jour et demi
sans aucun problème deux jours vous
pouvez les avoir si vous bourriner pas
si vous faites attention ça c'est plutôt
cool en plus vous avez des vrais stats
sur notre utilisation globale
vous voyez
vous consommez vous voyez vraiment ce
que vous allez consommer le pourcentage
c'est vraiment bien
vous avez des possibilités aussi pour
économiser votre batterie vous pouvez
activer automatiquement l'économiseur de
batteries pour devenir vraiment la
prolonger vous avez pas mal de
possibilités au niveau de l'optimisation
de votre batterie ya pas mal de petites
choses je trouve que là dessus il ya un
vrai boulot qui est très très très bien
fait on y re vraiment gagner en
autonomie et ça c'est super pour moi
l'autonomie pour ce one + 6 t est
vraiment excellent car en plus le fait
d'avoir la recharge rapide vous le
branchez en très peu de temps il est
chargé à 100% c'est vraiment hyper
appréciable et je trouve ça vraiment
génial et maintenant on va parler de l'
os et déjà de la navigation vous avez
soient vos boutons classiques sur un
android que vous pouvez retrouver là
soit vous avez une navigation par gestes
et c'est vraiment ce que je préfère
c'est à dire vous allez activer votre
navigation par geste est là pour le coup
c'est vraiment beaucoup mieux c'est plus
qu'on peut retrouver sur l'iphone dit ça
tout simplement hop vous maintenez vous
appuyer toutes vos applications
ça c'est cool vous glisser sur l'eau
vous swype et hop vous revenez sur
l'accueil et j'adore vraiment cette
navigation par gestes
à noter que vous avez un androïde 9.0
paille avec une surcouche oxygène os je
vous parlais à quelques instants du
match je vous aide dans vos paramètres
vous allez dans utilitaire vous allez
dans mode en jeu et là effectivement
vous avez tous vos paramètres répondre
aux appels via un haut-parleur vous
pouvez bloquer les notifications oui non
quoi comment les faire apparaître
vous avez pas mal de possibilités peut
désactiver la luminosité automatique
vous avez l'optimisation du réseau et
vous avez tous vos jeux qui sont en bas
remâche épargnants dreamer je joue avec
bg il est là mais vous pouvez mettre
tous vos jeux ça c'est plutôt cool au
niveau de votre stockage vous pouvez
complètement gérer vos stockage là vous
voyez ce qui est utilisé et vous voyez
ce qui vous reste de dispo pourrait
venir à libérer de l'espace si toutefois
vous en avez besoin
et vous voyez vraiment ce qui vous prend
de la place ce que vous avez à optimiser
ça aussi c'est plutôt cool en termes de
sécurité
ça fonctionne vraiment bien vous avez
google clé protect vous avez le
chiffrement des données qui est là vous
pouvez mettre bien évidemment vous
empreintes digitales en reconnaissance
faciale enfin si tous un peu classique
mais ça marche extrêmement bien
puisqu'on parle de sécurité dans les
utilitaires vous pouvez chiffres et des
applications si vous avez des
applications ce qu'elle vous voulez
vraiment protéger le contenu
vous pouvez venir les ajouter les
chiffres mêmes masqué notification et ce
en termes de sécu c'est vraiment bien
vous pouvez planifier la marche et
l'arrêt de l'appareil fin on va assez
loin quand même en termes de paramétrage
je me sens vraiment bien vous avez aussi
la migration oim de plus lorsque vous
les migrer d'un autre appareil android
ou alors bye os
actuellement dessus ça c'est aussi
vraiment vraiment cool est vraiment
toute une optimisation logiciel qui est
fait sur ce au moins de plus ce système
lowe s est très bien fonctionne très
bien et complètement optimisé avec la
machine ce qui fait qu'au final on a un
smartphone très rapide très puissant qui
est vraiment bien pour lier milk est
vraiment bien pour le jeu pour toutes
vos applications tous lancent très
rapidement une autonomie qui du coup est
accrue enfin une machine qui est une
vraie bête de compacter là-dessus - de
plus a fait un excellent travail il ya
un truc qui est important de souligner
aussi là dessus c'est que vous avez un
double lecteur carte sim ça c'est cool
c'est un peu dans les standards actuels
par contre vous ne pouvez absolument pas
augmenter votre capacité de stockage
donc lorsque vous allez acheter votre
one + 6 t pensez vraiment apprendre la
capacité de stockage dont vous avez
besoin donc sur une version de base dans
128 giga déjà vous êtes tranquille vous
allez de quoi faire vous avez de quoi
voir venir les poser vous vraiment la
question l'achat parce qu'il est
absolument impossible de venir
l'augmenter après ou pour mettre toutes
vos photos sur le cloud vous avez google
closier pas mal de possibilités dessus
ça aussi c'est peut être une option
mais si vous avez l'habitude de mettre
une carte microsd pour augmenter votre
capacité de stockage sachez que là
dessus c'est absolument pas possible
après vous avez aussi google paie grâce
au nfc qui à l'intérieur vous avez du
bluetooth 5.0 donc pour collecter tous
vos objets vous aurez absolument aucun
problème
sa smart fois que vous pouvez
précommander à partir du 30 octobre et
que vous pourrez ensuite à voir à partir
du 6 novembre ça vous intéresse je vous
invite tous les liens en bas dans la
description des que les précommandes
sont ouvertes comme ça - vous pouvez y
aller vous pouvez vous faire plaisir
si vous voulez pas tendre pour le tester
ce que je peut franchement comprendre
vous pouvez le retrouver dans les pop up
store de wad plus vous avez toutes les
infos sur mon twitter j'ai recruté les
zinfonautes plus donc vous pouvez aller
voir directement dessus également sur
mon facebook sur la page facebook pour
résumer moi vraiment ce qui me plaît
énormément sur ce nouveau one + 6 t
c'est le capteur d'empreintes digitales
directement alors c'est pas le bon doit
donc ça marche pas l'effet visuel est
juste incroyable
je trouve ça vraiment magnifique marche
extrêmement bien fait d'avoir un capteur
d'empreintes digitales directement sous
l'écran du mois en tout cas intégré à
l'écran ces nouvelles techno de cette
année voire plus ce n'est pas le premier
en tout cas est un des premiers à le met
ça fonctionne extrêmement bien c'est
faire appréciable j'aime également sept
ans coach que je trouve beaucoup plus
petit
du coup très discrète qui gêne
absolument pas vous avez un tout petit
haut parleurs cachés sur le dessus pour
passer des appels franchement ça marche
extrêmement bien c'est petite encoche
est beaucoup plus discrète que ce qu'on
avait sur le one piece site on trouve
qu'il ya un vrai bel effort a été fait
de la part one plus là dessus ça va
absolument pas a défiguré cet écran pour
tous ceux qui n'aiment pas les encoches
je suis vraiment aussi agréablement
surpris par l'autonomie je trouvais déjà
l'autonomie était très bonne forme en
plus si ça se trouve qu'on va encore
plus loin avec semaine + 6 t je vous dis
un jour et demi deux jours ça dépend
vraiment de votre utilisation c'est
toujours un petit peu compliqué à dire
au niveau de l'autonomie parce que ça
dépend de chacun ça dépend de ses usages
ça dépend sur le type d applications qui
sont gourmandes houllier dont deux jours
on peut les avoir deux jours on peut les
avoir si vous riez pas autre point qui
est excellent mais je vais développer
dans une prochaine vidéo c'est la partie
photo vidéo justement qui est excellente
ça y est vous le montrera plus tard
herman parce que sinon on peut faire une
vidéo qui va durer quatre heures
exactement que sur moins de plus ce
système
ça va être un petit peu compliqué et il
faut pas oublier la taille de cet écran
6,41 pousse ses énormes l'effet comique
toute petite encoche format 19 points
5/9 c'est vraiment hyper appréciable
pour regarder vos vidéos netflix youtube
tout ça c'est vraiment bien alors
presque je peux reprocher que ces
formats 19 points 5/9 19/9 ça lorsque
vous allez venir zoomer profiter de tout
l'écran qui passe on pourra d'une vidéo
où le protagoniste le héros vous parle
par exemple et qu'il est vraiment film
est comme ça le cadre est juste au
dessus de sa tête
vous allez bouffer un but de la tête ça
ça peut être un petit peu rédhibitoire
après ça dépend si on thin autres comme
ça par exemple plus en arrière là vous
pouvez venir vous mais ça veut dire
manger cette partie là si par contre je
me mets comme ça là tout de suite vous
allez manger la tronche voilà ça c'est
un petit peu le point un peu négatif
mais par contre on des jeux vidéo et
pour certaines vidéos pour des films ça
sera vraiment bien très immersif et en
tout cas c'est vraiment hyper âpre et
salé puis comme vous pouvez venir des
zooms et c'est pas vraiment un problème
est le dernier gros point qui est
vraiment hyper important là dessus qui
peut-être le point majeur c'est la
performance
vous avez autant la même fiche technique
et même spectre que vous aviez sur le
wan +6 il ya quelques mois par contre il
va encore plus vite toujours plus
optimisée d'un point de vue logiciel
c'est vraiment optimisé avec l'oxygène
os basé sur un android
- 0 paille ça marche du feu de dieu
c'est incroyable c'est vrai belle
machine est là dessus vous aurez
absolument aucun regret alors la
question est ce que je vous recommande
au final le one piece east et ma réponse
est un très grand oui le smartphone est
juste incroyable très rapide beau voilà
très très gros smartphone j'aime
beaucoup soin de plus ce système et
après si vous avez la possibilité je
vous déjà montré dans la vidéo de nbc
vous prenez up les petites coques qui
sont vraiment super et outils qui est
vraiment bien aussi qu'ils aient pas
forcément obligatoire c'est le casque
qui fonctionne extrêmement bien je
trouve ça super cool si ces produits
vous intéresse je vous mets un lien en
bas dans les sculptures vous dites moi
ce que vous en pensez est ce que vous
trouvez que ce one + 6 t es bien est ce
que vous trouvez points de plus a fait
un excellent boulot sur ce smartphone
comment vous trouvez le coche
comment vous trouvez c'est tout petit en
poche comment vous trouvez le capteur
d'empreintes digitales à l'écran comment
vous trouvez
je trouve que les faits - une redoutable
j'adore cet effet dites moi ce que vous
en pensez vous de marquer tout sans
commentaire on reste connectés et puis
abonnez-vous parce qu'on va parler dans
quelques jours de la partie photo vidéo
du wan fussistes et vous allez voir
c'est incroyable merci à vous soyez ça
je vous embrasse tous et à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]
oh